bonjour bruno mediapad merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
comment est-ce que vous accueillez la
décision de porter le masque de façon
obligatoire dans les lieux clos
c'est une très bonne décision nous
l'avions réclamé dans une tribune il y a
maintenant une petite semaine
effectivement dans les lieux clos
c'est là où la contamination entre les
individus et la plus importante et donc
lorsque l'on ne peut pas faire respecter
aux respecter la distanciation sociales
d'au moins 1 m il convient bien sûr de
mettre un masque pour rendre nulle
cette transmission de gouttelettes
puisque le virus se transmet
essentiellement par les gouttelettes
lorsque l'on tousse l'on parle où l'on
éternue et qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces internautes et à ceux qui estiment
que le masque on protège pas du commis
de 19 alors le masque en fait joue deux
rôles un premier rôle c'est un rôle de
barrière
donc en fait ils empêchent une personne
qui est porteuse du virus d'émettre des
gouttelettes vers les autres personnes
il joue également un deuxième rôle de
filtre
c'est à dire il va filtrer les
particules de plus de 3 microns qui sont
les particules en fait qui contiennent
les virus et qui sont les particules
contaminantes et donc il joue aussi un
rôle de protection de soi même pour
éviter d'être contamination contaminés
en fait il existe de plus en plus des
preuves sérieuses et formelle
d'efficacité du port du masque
généralisée pour réduire la
contamination en fin de semaine passée
deux études sont ont été publiés dans
des revues internationales montrant de
façon scientifique l'intérêt du masque
pour réduire définitivement la
transmission alors c'est s'il ya deux
exemples qui ont été donc donné le
premier c'est dans un salon de coiffure
ou deux coiffeurs été contaminés et plus
de 200 personnes qui ont fréquenté ce
salon n'ont aucune d'entre elles n'a été
contaminé par ce que le port du masque
avait été rendu
y at war le deuxième exemple et dans un
hôpital de très grande taille où
effectivement la généralisation
universel du masque pour les soignants
et les patients dans tous les lieux y
compris administratif a réduit la
contamination des soignants par rapport
à la période où seul le masque était
nécessaire dans les lieux de soins
plus de 460 personnes testées positives
en mayenne des foyers de contamination
en bretagne en nouvelles aquitaine selon
certains experts il y aurait des signaux
d'alerté de reprise épidémique alarmisme
démesurée ou prévention raisonnée alors
je dirais pour le moment il faut encore
être serein le virus circule un niveau
relativement bas en france même si cette
circulation augmente on estime que la
circulation actuelle est de 4,3 nouveaux
cas pour 100000 habitants en france
néanmoins dans certaines régions
notamment la mayenne et bien cette
circulation semble avoir augmenté de
façon plus importante 58,9 nouveaux cas
en sept jours pour 100000 habitants et
donc effectivement il y a des petits
signaux d'inquiétude le but de rendre le
masque obligatoire dans les lieux clos
public dès à présent est de nous
permettre d'envisager sereinement
l'arrivée de l'automne sans devoir
confinés comme ça à l'air d'être le cas
dans un certain nombre de pays qui nous
entourent
vous travaillez en réanimation quelle
est la situation dans votre service en
ce moment même et s'il ya une
augmentation des cas de patients
attendent et coronavirus qui nécessitent
une prise en charge en respiration
artificielle
alors donc nous avions toujours la
présence de deux patients qui étaient
entrées lors de la première vague
donc voici depuis trois mois ils sont en
réanimation leur situation s'est
nettement améliorée
ils vont bientôt sortir du service
al'inverse dans les quinze derniers
jours nous avons accueilli deux nouveaux
patients donc contaminés depuis la levée
du confinement d'ailleurs de personnes
habitant en france donc par une
contamination communautaire à paris
malheureusement de leur situation
justifier d'une ventilation artificielle
et est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un nouveau
risque pas pardonnez moi ce qu'il peut y
avoir un nouveau risque de voir les
services de réanimation saturé en vo est
ce que les services hospitaliers sont
préparer à une deuxième vague épidémique
alors les services hospitaliers sont
parfaitement préparés à accueillir des
patients notamment ceux qui seraient
gravement affectées
néanmoins le but c'est d'éviter
l'infection et pour permettre aux
services hospitaliers de soigner
correctement les quelques rares cas que
qui pourraient se présenter il faut que
la totalité de la population puisse
appliquer les mesures barrières et
mettre le masque donc désormais
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
pour réduire ce risque de contamination
sépare la prévention que l'on réduira le
nombre de patients infectés et gravement
affecté que l'on permettra aux services
de soin de faire face à l'épidémie
merci bruno megaman d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes le
chef du service réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière dans la capitale française